ah ah ah
mais les malades non mais des tarifs
[Musique]
allaient faudrait un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour la montagne tort
et avec le temps
un tranquille tu regrettes bonsoir il va
te péter label regarde le pack commence
lui mais pas un doigt dans le cul cyril
journo fatmi ya six mois six mois il m'a
demandé si j'avais dû feu
alors notre métier
[Rires]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va faire un exercice donc dans
l'instant il va porter matthieu
delormeau et levon porte artois de 6 kg
on va voir celui qui reste plus
longtemps un parent trap pour travailler
de matthieu delormeau à bout de bras oui
comme moi dans cette émission son slogan
c'est fuck plastique bottles parce que
il défend l'environnement tort bien sûr
on le connaît 1 de game of thrones et la
montagne mais là il est là aujourd'hui
pour sensibiliser les français aux
plastiques almatois quand même méchante
bouteilles des zones spéciales a bien
pas bien d'accord vous poser combien 80
81 kg et vous vous avez un poids de 6 kg
va voir celui tient peu plus longtemps
mais les malades non mais des tarés
à celle en haut
le punk la 81 kg quand même
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]